là quelques temps on avait parlé de ce
qui se passe dans notre corps quand on
devient vieux et sais pas si vous vous
souvenez mais comme tout ça c'était un
petit peu théorique je vous avais
proposé de se livrer à une petite
expérience pour des choses plus
concrètes voilà ce qu'on va faire je
vais devenir vieux le temps d'une
journée et je vous montre ce que ça
donne dans une prochaine vidéo
via le moment est venu pour ça laissez
moi juste le temps de me mettre dans la
peau d'une personne âgée vieux croulants
fin quand fou alcan transformation voilà
je porte un simulateur de vieillissement
désormais mes articulations sont raides
mes mouvements sont limités au niveau
des mains au niveau des poignets des
coudes au niveau des genoux au niveau du
tout est désormais l'emploi des termes
comme désormais je suis vieux mabut est
perturbée par un glaucome ou par une
cataracte ou par une dégénérescence
maculaire et ma petite touche
personnelle
non je sais que vous pensez mais c'est
pas ça c'est pour la presbyacousie c'est
à dire la baisse de l'audition arrive
pas les mettre tout seul voilà
maintenant j'ai 80 ans vous allez le
sucre je vis ma vie et on va voir
comment ça se passe c'est parti
voilà donc début de la journée
comme en super bien parce que j'ai dormi
sur mon canapé étant donné que ma
chambre est à l'état et que les
escaliers c'est compliqué voilà je sais
pas vous mais moi la première chose que
je fais je me réveille c'est de prendre
une bonne douche pour bien commencer la
journée
alors fait partie donc erreur la
première chose que je fais quand je me
réveille manifestement c'est me lever
voilà des luttes et ne rend pas compte
mais là je me rends bien compte que
c'est compliqué
je gère ça comme ça parce que je peux
pas encore le mans bon alors
manifestement savait difficile de
prendre un but comme ça en attendant de
faire installer une petite cabine
on va faire ça a lancé
voilà comment sous laon sont mieux un
aller en tout cas fait maintenant jours
c'est pas comme la défense
à
alors par contre je sais pas vous mais
moi le café alors par contre là vous
venez pas avec moi on est d'accord
non non non vraiment je vais pas vous
mentir c'est pas très pratique non plus
bien souvent ces papys d'amy allez on
part sur un petit fipa alors bravo
j'arrive pas du tout ouais non ok et en
plus je vois rien avec une cataracte de
ces lieux là bas eba dont je n'arrive
plus à faire le mort aux dents c'est
pierre jarillon lui tout est alors avec
la dégénérescence maculaire fait c'est
mieux donc là vraiment je vois
absolument est multicarte toujours pas à
tout et avec les doigts bien bon sa part
sur un échec
bon j'ai la dalle donc là un truc à
bouffer up aux bêtes c'est qu'on prend
l'habitude aller
et je ne peux pas
on va partir sur un câble du coût en
année
bashary
alors un kebab ou est-ce qu'on instaure
je comprends pourquoi ma grand-mère a
répond jano des premiers cours
c'est bizarre parce qu'avec les bouchons
à l'intérieur autant la j'entendais tout
autant là avec le boulet voiture en
peluche encore plus rien comprendre un
kebab frites franchi
tu es ma rue
tu as je crois que c'est parfait dans la
merde non c'est une feuille
[ __ ] ça y est on est arrivé on a vu
arriver
bon c'est un peu froid un placement
taylor on part sur une arthrite
on part sur
quand vous
ah [ __ ] c'était bon bon allez
maintenant vous venez je vais faire
l'amour je suis pour aujourd'hui aller
je suis épuisé des transformations
l'orage pas claquer des doigts là mais
encore là c'était juste pour une journée
et sont toutes les galères de prostate
sont toutes les douleurs ils sont tous
ces petits trucs qui peuvent encore
compliqué la vie quand on est vieux et
dont on avait déjà parlé dans la
première vidéo
je ne sais pas ce que vous retenez de
cette expérience moi perso ce que je
retiens c'est que quand on est vieux to
pay plus compliqué même les trucs les
plus basiques de la vie quotidienne et
ça veut dire que du coup il faut sans
arrêt trouver des stratégies
d'adaptation à tous ces changements
et ça c'est épuisant ce que je me dis
aussi encore une fois c'est que ça coûte
pas cher d'être patient avec les
personnes âgées au lieu de les speed et
parce qu'on trouve qu'ils vont pas assez
vite que elle aussi elle trouve qu'elles
vont pas assez vite
sauf que pour elles c'est toute la
journée tout le temps d'ailleurs si on
veut on peut même leur donner un coup de
main c'est pas interdit dans tout ce
qu'on peut leur proposer parce que
n'oubliez pas demain des vieux ce sera
vous voit la dtcc fini pour aujourd'hui
on se retrouve très vite pour une
nouvelle vidéo en attendant je fais un
gros bisou à ma mémé et à vous aussi